E.
Computadores quânticos são muito sensíveis ao ruído
perturbações que causam erros
nas suas computações, mas uma nova pesquisa mostra
os computadores ruidosos da IBM correspondendo a métodos clássicos exatos
e verificando os regimes e superando sofisticados métodos clássicos
de aproximação em ambos os regimes verificáveis
e em regimes sem solução de arquivo
para um desafiador experimento de simulação.
Como eles conseguem isso? Eles usam uma técnica especial
para lidar com o ruído
em sistemas quânticos, chamada mitigação de erros.
Com a técnica de mitigação de erros
usada neste experimento, executamos nossos cálculos
e aumentamos o ruído gradualmente.
Depois extrapolamos de volta para a resolução sem ruído.
Este trabalho nos aproxima um passo de uma computação quântica útil
nós